board announcing today it's going to
return to the mall one of the most
prestigious automobile races in the
world with its new Ford GT race car is
based on the all new supercar that goes
on sale next year Matt Miller our
resident car expert is standing by with
for chairman Bill Ford thanks very much
PIM and Bill thanks so much for joining
us congratulations great to see you
there in front of that gorgeous GTE
raised car in Paris let me ask you what
got you back in till the mall and why
choose the GTE class a lot of people
were speculating you might go LM p2
which is kind of a more experimental
class well first of all Matt you should
be here because you of all people would
really appreciate this it's been a great
day look we decided to come back to
Lomond because we actually finally had
the car to do it and compete and and
make no mistake we want to win so when
we set about developing this car you
know a couple years ago racing was very
much part of the discussion and in terms
of the class of wherein that seemed it
we talked to chip ganassi who's going to
be our race team and chip thought that
was the place where we should start any
idea yet bill on who's going to drive
this car well if you and I are out of
the equation I guess that means we're
gonna have to find somebody else it's
too early but you know you would
obviously expect us to be talking to
drivers and their no shortage of drivers
that are lining up to drive this are we
gonna see do you think American drivers
here because you were the first to win
an American Championship at lamang back
in what 1966 and it would be great to
see that happen again well it would in
fact in 66 we finished one two and three
and then we won for the next four years
in a row and it was a great run you know
we're actually running two circuits Matt
we're doing the tutor Series in America
and we're doing the WEC series over here
do you I mean racing is exciting and
obviously everybody is pumped up about
it today but it's a very
capital-intensive endeavor why from a
business angle do you pursue that sort
of thing
because a lot of what we're doing in
this vehicle we can actually translate
to our other vehicles we do a lot of
firsts on our race cars and you probably
notice that we're doing an EcoBoost
engine in this vehicle all the light
waiting and also they are dynamics that
we went into this vehicle those will
start to make their way into our
mainstream product so a lot of what we
do with racing really is developmental
for the rest of our product line I
wonder how much it works as a marketing
tool because racing viewership
Motorsports you ership hasn't really
been a tear I think it's gone down and a
lot of different leagues is it still a
great marketing tool for Ford well it is
I mean first of all it's great for the
brand image and people who like racing
pay a lot of attention to the
manufacturer and so yes it is important
but it's also important to our own
employees because they get fired up to
be able to work on a vehicle like this
and our dealers love to see is competing
hey Bill you know you started this
because your Uncle Henry Ford to was
very close to a merger with Johnny egg
Nelly and Enzo Ferrari and that went
sour I wonder if you've talked to any
members of the egg nellie family about
the possibility of a collaboration
lately for example john l Connors
representative Sergio Marconi well John
Elkann and I are friends and I've known
John for years and I like him very much
but you know we're very happy where we
are but you know Sergio says there's a
very capital-intensive issue with
developing cars 30 different car makers
spending 2.2 billion dollars a week to
make somewhat redundant technology don't
you think consolidation needs to happen
in the auto industry you know Matt
people have been talking about this
since i joined the industry in the back
in the late 70s and everybody predicted
that within ten years back then there
would be two european to american and
two asian car manufacturers well not
only did that not happen but we have
many more manufacturers than we did even
10 years ago logically yes you
would have capacity coming out but
frankly even if you merge that doesn't
guarantee anything you still have to
take the action to take capacity out let
me ask you speaking of capacity about
building vehicles and aluminum the GT
behind you the GT supercar from
2005-2006 was your first experience
putting aluminum bodies on performance
cars now you're putting them on all
f-150s and they're selling like hotcakes
but you can't make enough of them have
you been able to get back to a maximum
production and build up some inventory
with the f-150 well it's the good-news
bad-news problem the bad news is we
can't build inventory because the good
news is we're selling them all it we are
now at full production at our two
assembly plants but as you point out we
really have great demand which is
fantastic but we are racing to keep up
with it all right well speaking of
racing going to wish you the best of
luck there I will send my application to
you and Chip Ganassi for one of the
drivers spots in the 2016 limahl GTE
class thanks very much bill for it